all right Ben Shapiro so you're on NRA
TV and obviously so we're very big on
the Second Amendment and it's what we
focus on mostly on this program not all
the time but mostly let me ask you when
it comes to young people the millennial
generation what do you think and where
do they stand when it comes to guns does
it mimic the older population where
those on the Left have this idea that
somehow they're bad except for in the
south and maybe middle middle America or
is there an awakening going on among
young people and Firearms in your
opinion I mean I think there is
something of an awakening going on I
think there's a libertarian streak that
runs very strong in people of my age and
below just where they say we don't want
government involved in any of our stuff
and that includes guns I will say
there's a cultural gap no question now I
grew up in Los Angeles I went to law
school in Boston there are a lot of
people who grew up around me who have
never seen a gun in person have never
held the gun and so they see guns as
inherently frightening as inherently
spooky as inherently like the gun is
going to take on a life of its own and
shoot somebody and you have to be
trained out of that I mean you really
have to be given almost in an aversion
therapy you actually have to train with
a gun you have to go to a range have to
be taught by somebody who knows what
they're doing I grew up that way not
holding guns now I own a couple of guns
myself but that's because you know I
actually put forth the effort to go and
get educated and and learn how to do it
I think that you know a lot of the work
the NRA does and educating people is
gonna make a big difference there the
more the more people have actually seen
and fired a gun and and seen that it's a
it's a tool rather than in in evil in
and of itself I think that the better
the gun rights movement will do among
young people all right I'm going to ask
you a question I'm going to put you on
the spot here and either answer it is
okay all right are you a member of the
NRA I don't think I'm technically a
member of the NRA I did what a prize
from the NRA back when I was in law
school for for a law essay that I wrote
actually but I don't think that I'm
technically a member all right well that
was for several years actually that's to
me speaks very highly of the NRA right
we're going to give you a ward even if
you're not a member no problem there
something a group like the NRA would do
and be all for here's the reason why I
asked you one I would love to have you
as a member and and look we need young
people whether we have great
conservative thinkers who are wildly
famous like yourself ben shapiro
or just other young people out there who
were just trying to make it make their
way we need young people what do you
think our message should be here at NREL
Ras message to reach out to more young
people to get them to join because I
would not be intellectually honest if I
didn't say that we need to make it a
goal of ours because we cannot let all
the membership you know pass through
here without signing up younger people I
think that the best thing that you guys
can do is a lot of the stuff that you're
already doing in terms of saying to
young people that your rights are under
assault and also that even if you're not
somebody who's been familiar with guns
these are tools that you should you
should get to know this is something
that you should know about instead of
just being scared about about something
that you've never spent any time with so
your educational programs first and then
you say you know now that you've been
educated about what a firearm is what it
does and how to use it
now you can talk about rights I think
that starting with the rights argument
is probably losing argument getting
people familiar with what you're talking
about then making the rights argument is
a winning one yeah I will tell you and I
and well obviously I'm biased but there
is great power and there is strength in
numbers there is no doubt and the NRA as
five million members were instrumental
in getting Donald Trump elected and the
only way to continue that power is to
have more and more members come on board
no question I mean I've always thought
that the NRA does fantastic work in
protecting Second Amendment rights and
and without that without the NRA doing
that work and despite the media's lies
about what the NRA does the NRA is a
popular grassroots organization this is
not something where you guys are being
paid by the gun lobby because you're
corrupt is there millions of Americans
who feel that their gun rights have to
be protected by someone I think that's
what the NRA stands well no and my
message to young people would be it's
not just about the guns it's about the
freedom and you could almost make the
argument that it's more about the
freedom and the guns are there to
protect that Ben no question I mean
that's an argument I've been making my
entire career with regard to gun rights
is that in the end what stands between
you and tyranny is is the power of the
weapon in your hands and the power of
the goodness in your heart and if you
combine those two things that's how you
maintain a free country that's how our
free country was won in the first place
all right last question four-year any
other colleges out there and now have
your picture with devil horns coming out
of your
had on their walls graffiti eyes and all
of it all of that thing you got any
plans for speeches where they're not
gonna let you speak well I'm not sure
about the the band's yet but we are
speaking I believe three times on the
East Coast at the end of this month
we're speaking four times throughout the
country at the end of February so I
think we have something like 12 to 15
more colleges that we're going to be
visiting between the beginning of this
year and and the end of April I think
you know my biggest problem with
universities today and when I went to
school I graduated in 1991 certainly
there was a liberal bent to where I went
to school but I still don't remember
professors telling me what to think I
really still believe when I was at
school maybe it was the last great years
of colleges and I went to a little
liberal arts school in the middle of
Ohio where it would be bastion ly
liberal but they taught me how to think
and how to be a critical thinker not
what to think and I don't think that's
happening in our colleges and
universities today I think increasingly
it's it's minority viewpoint that
they're teaching people to think for
themselves is worthwhile more often it
seems like there are professors who are
interested in teaching you that what
they think is the is the correct way to
think that what they're teaching you is
fact as opposed to their opinion I don't
want to say that's true for all
professors I think there are a lot of
great professors out there but
increasingly the the ivory tower effect
has had a significant negative impact I
think on the teaching profession all
right Ben Shapiro it's great having you
on the pro you want me to send you a
membership application and happy parade
ease up never sounds good maybe I'll
even pay the the small amount it is for
the first year buddy thank you for
coming on me thanks a lot I appreciate
it